I'm moving this
thing not back on the
L it starts when I move
this all your strikes okay moving this
then the
arm
this
[Applause]
okay let's
try so as you're coming through you want
to feel the feet so here I don't feel
the feet I'm like just going to hold him
okay you you feel for his
[Music]
feet that's how you get his balance cuz
eventually his feet are going to pin
he'll he'll get a step his feet will pin
but the inertia keeps going and that's
where he loses his balance that adds
times to my action side I take a guy and
I just pull him he runs with it he turns
around it's right there you have to take
his balance so feet that's what you
want
boom
okay give you
time feet gives you time to do what you
need to do okay